ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde und wir dürfen
gar nicht lange zeit verlieren denn ich
habe wieder extrem viel auf der to do
liste für heute zuallererst möchte ich
allerdings mal ganz kurz das ja an der
weiter abbauen
das habe ich mir nämlich in der letzten
folge noch mal angeguckt und diesen
kleinen seitensprung von demokratien
baum fand ich dann doch nicht so schön
weshalb ich das jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
eben abbauen werde hier die sachen weckt
und so sieht das auf jeden fall schon
ein bißchen klima aus was mir auch unten
in die kommentare geschrieben wurde war
luca du kannst hier einfach seide nehmen
und das hier mit dem zweiteiler
verbinden und dann hier auch diesen
teppich hin packen also hier den weiß
nicht teppich und auf den roten teppich
das sollte auf jeden fall machbar sein
dass test mir nachher auf jeden fall
auch noch zuallererst ich will mich
allerdings erstmal nach dort ganz hinten
wo unsere tier insel demnächst
stattfinden soll denn dort packt unser
boot irgendwie seit 4000 folgen ich habe
keine ahnung warum ihr dass sie
irgendwann haben stehen lassen alles
klar der gau direkt wieder ab gar keinen
bock auf dich und jetzt werde ich auch
bei ganz schnell hinten zu unserem dorf
fand man das sieht schon schön aus ja
alles mit den inseln sind schon richtig
froh bei unsere kleine welt na ja ich
werde auf jeden fall so dem wasser
dorthin fahren was wir vor irgendwelchen
keine ahnung wie vielen folgen mal
entdeckt haben und ich werde endlich ihn
nicht das schaf abholen macht euch keine
hoffnung
ich war hier auf jeden fall zu dem
kleinen dörfchen denn um einen weiteren
villiger zu holen und den dann mit
meinem village auf meiner insel sich
paaren zu lassen so dass wir neue kleine
billiger bekommen
von daher schob sich den jetzt einfach
mal hier rein bzw werde ich glaube ich
zwar einfach so vorgehen dass ich hier
den weg ein bisschen abbauen werde und
mit dem boot einfach direkt hier
vorfahren wäre so dass sich die quasi
direkt hier rein bewegen kann ich hoffe
mal das funktioniert ich bin jetzt hier
mit dem hütchen und kann ihn jetzt noch
einschieben
es ist doch einfach möglich seien
falsche richtung fahrtrichtung richtige
richtung richtige richteten rein hier
rüber ins boot
nein ich hier oben hin du sollst rüber
ins boot und sagt wir haben den
willicher drin und verlassen auch direkt
wieder die das kleine dörfchen denn wir
haben ganz ganz ganz ganz viel auf der
to-do-liste zunächst einmal möchte ich
mich dafür entschuldigen dass die letzte
episode minecraft mit luca vorgestern
eine viertelstunde zu spät online gegen
ich hatte probleme mit meinem ränder
programm beziehen wir sie mit meinem
schnittprogramm weshalb ich ein paar
fehler hatte und dann das video nicht
pünktlich online gehen konnte
von daher weil dort einige kommentare
kamen von wegen das wird schon zu spät
blabla doch mal mein nett gemeinte
appelle an euch wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanalseite abonniert
main kanal gern ist das kostenlos und
ihr könnt euch jederzeit umentscheiden
und man kann er wieder der abonnierten
falls euch nicht gefallen sollte was
sich hochladen allerdings könnt ihr wenn
ihr auf die glocke klickt die
benachrichtigungen aktivieren das geile
daran ist dass sie einfach eine
benachrichtigung bekommt sobald man
neues video hochgeladen ist das heißt
egal ob schmal 8 uhr wird oder mal
viertel nach acht oder mal führte vor
ort oder irgendwie so ihr seid immer auf
dem neuesten stand und ihr seid immer
darüber informiert wenn ein neues video
von mir online geht das wenn ich auf
jeden fall sehr cool denn dann kann man
direkt so missverständnisse aus dem weg
gehen wenn mal ein video später kommt
weil nicht jeder der mir auf 'youtube'
volk folgte auf instagram wo ich euch
immer up to date halte wenn ich
irgendwelche probleme haben im schnitt
und weiter und so fort
das wollte ich auch ganz gut sagen und
was ich auch sagen wollte und das seht
ihr schon an meiner route die ich hier
gerade fahre der normalerweise fahre ich
einmal da vorne neben den inseln hierher
die sache ist dass ich hier gerade dann
fahre weil ich noch mal in das blumen
um muss und mir dort einigen an einige
ich muss mir ein bisschen flieder
besorgen und diesem flieger benötige ich
weit ich magenta farbenen farbresten der
das sind der viel ist das klima ist das
flipout schon wieder weg aber wir wissen
auf jeden fall dass er noch lebt das
freut mich auf jeden fall extrem wir
benötigen flieder hier vorne wie ich
bereits gerade schon gesagt habe für
magento farbe in den farbstoff und da
fragt ihr euch jetzt auch wahrscheinlich
hätte luca postident-verfahren den
farbstoff
ich möchte mir ja eine neue portal insel
bauen und dann möchte ich so ein
bisschen mit glasarbeiten und so weiter
und so fort ich weiß nicht ob das gut
aus doch das war eine große hürde da
gerade ich weiß ja dass gut aussehen
wird und ich weiß noch nicht ob alles so
klappen wird wie ich es mir vorstelle
denn das tutorial wo ich mir die
inspiration geholt habe war auf
japanisch und ich kann kein japanisch
von daher weiß ich nicht ob das alles so
klappen wird wie es mir vorstelle
allerdings ist das hier schon direkt der
flieder die mehr haben das habe ich dir
richtig erkannt ich blumen spezialist so
dass sie vorne mitnehmen dass hier
mitnimmt sagte mir schon fünf stück wir
benötigen insgesamt zwölf lieder habe
ich mir hier nebenan aufgeschrieben ich
habe mich wieder extrem gut vorbereitet
die heute die sonne geht auch schon so
das heißt wir müssen auf jeden fall ein
gang zulegen
dass es kein flieger aber das hier auf
jeden fall genau haben wir vorne noch
ein bisschen was hier ist auf jeden fall
noch flieder und das wird er in school
also ich denke mal das wird ganz geil
die portal insel da freue ich mich auf
jeden fall drauf hier vorne steht auch
noch ein bisschen flieder und was ich
auch noch sagen wollte war
ich bin cool hier vorne noch eben den
flieger mitnehmen und hier auch und hier
hinter befindet sich auch noch was dann
haben wir auf jeden fall auch noch mal
ein bisschen wasservorrat falls wir uns
verbauen sollten die sonne geht schon
unter und ihr seht es wird immer dunkler
von daher packe ich mal ganz kurz die
fackel in meine zweite hand hier vorne
so dass wir alles immer so ein bisschen
beleuchtet haben und es muss ich
irgendwie mein boot wieder finden hier
vorne ist es allerdings auch schon von
daher ganz schnell mal gedreht zacken
der 5 modus gehen und ich nennt euch
kurz mal ebene time lab sein wie ich zu
meiner insel fahren
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder
angekommen ich sehe bisher noch kein
keeper ihr in der nähe von da her da
kommt ein zombie ich werde einfach mal
die leute zwei mixed hier das kannst du
ja nicht aus dinge
kannst du dir doch nicht ausdenken ich
werde jetzt mal direkt schlafen gehen
weil ich keine lust habe dass mir hier
irgendwer irgendwas in luft sprengt hier
oben fehlt auch immer noch das laub was
wir abbauen mussten als der überfall
stattgefunden hat allerdings begrüße ich
euch erstmal recht herzlich zu einem
wunderschönen neuen morgen hier in
meiner kleinen süßen kraftfeld meine
liebe freunde ich werde das jetzt direkt
mal machen denn ich dafür liebt mich nie
so viel zeit verlieren und mir immer so
viele sachen vorher schiebe ich muss
projekte direkt angehen sonst wird
dieses ganze projekt wirklich sondern
flughafen berlin 2 0 vorne liegt auch
noch eine menge eichenlaub um das hätte
ich mal ganz kurz einsammeln
beziehungsweise ist aktien lobnig kann
es auf jeden fall einsammeln aber es ist
doch aktien auf so egal das alles jetzt
mal beiseite wir werden jetzt erstmal
den will und welche vor darüber auf
meine insel bringen
hier fordern wir immer noch das kleine
trittbrett für ihn von daher hier sagt
bauen wir das brötchen hier für ihn ab
so ich nehme das brötchen los ist ich
habe keine ahnung wo das brötchen ist
als kollege schlüssen komme rub.de wie
hier ausgesetzt und den ganzen gruppe um
dahin zu gehen wo was deine mission dann
wollt ihr mich verarschen älter sieht
das nicht aus also ich weiß nicht wie
ich ihnen jetzt darüber kriege das könnt
ihr mir gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
allerdings brauche ich den will ja
eigentlich hier vorne auf der insel so
dass erhalten pharmawerte meine farm
dahinten managt allerdings soll es darum
auch gar nicht gehen heute denn ich
möchte erstmal ganz kurz gucken ob das
jetzt geklappt mit dem flieger
denn ich bekomme hier perfekt 32
magentafarbenen farbstoff das bringt mir
jetzt gerade allerdings erst mal nichts
denn ich benötige trotzdem noch 177 glas
so ihr seht schon unten im inventar
eingeblendet ich habe auf jeden fall
deutlich mehr sand geholt als sich auf
jeden fall gebraucht hätte die sache ist
allerdings dass ich für dieses
dauerprojekt hier vorne also für die
strandhaus moderne villa situation auch
noch eine menge glas benötige von daher
habe ich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
mehr mitgenommen wo ich das schon mal
war die sonne geht schon wieder unter
das heißt wir müssen uns auf jeden fall
noch mal eine runde schlafen legen ihr
fordert sieht schon gut aus mit dem
magazin baumann mit der kleinen strand
liegen situationen hier ich parkbad kurz
hier vorne
ich rede immer noch auf dass der winter
nicht auf unsere anderen insel tür zu
wichtig wegen einbrechern mich regt
immer noch auf dass der andere villiger
auf meiner insel jetzt ist nicht auf der
willicher insel als ich weiß wirklich
nicht wie ich den rüber kriegen soll ich
habe keine ahnung hab ich dir irgendwie
alleine packen kann oder keine ahnung
was allerdings könnt ihr mir da immer
gerne und in die kommentare schreiben
falls sie da irgendwelche tipps und
tricks zu wisst und zu haben ich habe
gerade schon mal ein bisschen mehr sand
in mainkofen hier vorne rein getan dass
brutzelt jetzt vor sich hin 37 grad habe
ich schon ich kann noch einmal ganz kurz
gucken ob das überhaupt klappt ich packe
jetzt erstmal nur vier glas rum und ein
bisschen farbstoff ja es läuft auf jeden
fall ich krieg 32 magenta farben eine
glasglocke raus und kann euch einmal
ganz kurz zeigen wie das aussehen wird
nämlich so und dann perfekt jetzt habe
ich schon ein glas blog verschwendet was
ihr allerdings ebenfalls bereits
unschwer erkennen könnte ist dass ich
mir hier noch 52 ketten getrachtet habe
die benötige ich auch noch für meine
neue insel und ich habe mir noch ein
eichenholz schild schon mal mitgenommen
denn das habe in der letzten folge ein
bisschen vergessen
der lupo baum platziert das schild hier
dran schreibe hier ein hashtag lupu an
alle die mich kennen sollten weg ich
klicke auch fertig und wenn man hier
jetzt ganz einfach rechtsweg drauf macht
einfach die wahrheit dem einfach mal das
brötchen hier und nehmen das mit rüber
vorne zu meiner kleinen insel hier denn
eventuell kommen wir den weg über den
fluss hier gehen
ich setze das hier ein
jetzt muss ich den filter nur dahin
schieben können nein nein nein nein
gegen das motorrad bekommst du kommst
hier mit darüber kommen jetzt hier hin
da muss ich dir das extra für den
brauche ich jetzt hier in wekeln und ich
muss den ganzen weg gleich wieder neu
machen extra damit der wille darüber
kommt wird auf die willicher insel
meine lieben freunde das kannst du doch
wirklich nicht ausdenken hier das brot
hin und du musst zwei blöcke gehen ab in
das büdchen rhein nicht ein nicht
einrichtung ja ins boot rein millionen
das kriegst du doch wohin du gehst da
rein
du gehst ein bisschen noch eine 11 warum
geht er nicht warum geht er nicht in das
boot wie kann das denn sein muss ich ihm
das hier auch noch abbauen oder was
alter das kann doch nicht das kannst du
nicht angeben und jedes boot einfach nur
da rein genehmigung einfach nur dich in
bahrain setzte auto setzte sich da nicht
bald ein bisschen runterkommen
manchmal gehts nur mit gewalt
er merkt euch das nicht ich bin kein
gutes vorbild ist sie fordern möchte ich
mal ganz kurz wieder zusammen machen das
habe ich mir letztes schon gedacht dass
das eigentlich so gut passt wenn die
steine hier untergehen sondern hier
sollte auch einfach so ein bisschen sand
seinen 17 natürlicher aus und ich setze
mich jetzt bei ihm ihr mit 31 25 und wir
machen eine rot das war's na gut
ja wir werden es auf jeden fall ihn hier
rüber bringen zu unserer kleinen insel
ich hoffe mal dass sie sich jetzt merkt
dass er halt hier rein muss bei 10
ich weiß was ich mache das von anderen
seite ich habe keinen bock dass er sich
wieder dazu entschließt zu anderen seite
rüber zu schwimmen ich wollte heute
eigentlich noch die portal insel bhola
allerdings klinge das leider nicht in
die letzten beiden folgen waren ja schon
wieder extrem angucken wie ein kumpel
für die ich bin genommen wird sehen wir
hier die erde in dem bisschen
runterbremsen kleinen weg sogar zum
doppelten weil er ein bisschen dicker
ist so ne frau mir das büdchen ab und
sagt und jetzt musst du einfach nur
[Musik]
wir lassen die beiden da vorne einfach
mal machen und sehen auch schon dass die
sonne schon wieder untergeht von daher
gehen wir auch noch mal ganz kurz wieder
schlafen ich bin der rufname schon bei
mehr als einer stunde weil das mit dem
winter wieder so lange gedauert hat die
sache ist allerdings was ich auf jeden
fall noch ein bisschen mehr schaffen
möchte für heute und zwar hier noch mal
so ein bisschen mit glas ryanair 2
beziehungsweise sand rein denn wir
benötigen
das ist ob sie ihren wir müssen auch
noch in der heutigen folge eigentlich in
den nenner gehen um eine menge schwarz
stress stress streng um eine menge
schwarz steigen zu fahren davon
benötigen wir insgesamt 786 für meine
neue portal insel darf ich auf jeden
fall auch bock drauf mal wieder in den
neckar zu geben die beiden sind defekt
das heißt der andere ist glaube ich
jetzt wirklich dauerhaft auf unserer
insel
das kann man ganz kurz gucken ob ihr
vorne sich jetzt schon bettchen teilen
oder was hier abgeht
er schläft hier und der andere hier
bitte die ja es klappt auf jeden fall
ich gehe schlafen meine lieben freunde
und würde auch an der stelle die heutige
episode minecraft mit luca beenden wir
haben auch mein gott hat mich relativ
schnell mal schlafen gehen und warten
dass neuer attacken bricht habt nicht so
lustig auf diese ganzen monster hier
tata in wunderschöner morgen erwartet
uns in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt da hinten das schiff das sieht
schon schön auf die vorne sind patienten
fisch es auch nicht freue mich jetzt mal
wieder eine schöne episode weil am ende
der letzten episode wo das mit der eine
schildkröte war und dann auch noch mit
den ganzen das hatten wir dann noch für
die situation letztens wo hier noch ein
paar leute gestorben sind die hierhin
packen musste
das war immer so schön deswegen freue
ich mich heute wieder eine ganz normale
kurze entspannt episode zu haben
das brot werde ich mir auf gewarnt die
nächste episode so dass sie da hinten
sich weiter vermehren können
was ich allerdings noch bevor ich die
folge beendet ganz kurz machen wollte
war
ich auf jeden fall töten was ich machen
wollte war das hatte ich nämlich in der
letzten aufnahme gesehen dass das hier
der bauen sich auch nicht so schön aus
habe ich auch ein bisschen zu viel weg
gemacht bzw
die räuber haben auch diesen baum ein
bisschen beschädigt von daher wollte ich
hier in anderen baum hin pflanzen und
eventuell fast ja hier sogar akazien das
wäre geil wenn die ich hier so hoch
kommen würde dann zur seite rüber
allerdings möchte ich die doch gar nicht
in pflanzen sondern glaube ich baue ich
da einfach ein magazin baum hin ich
finde es eigentlich immer schöner wenn
man die beule sich so wachsen und
vermehren lässt wie es halt gewollt ist
allerdings klappt das ja nicht immer und
wie man es haben will ist es oft dann
auch nicht so richtig
von daher werde ich da jetzt einfach mal
der kac hinbauen und hoffen dass das
ganze klappt so wie es mir vorstelle
denn so wie der hier ist den wollte ich
eigentlich hier über haben das können
wir hier vorne dann allerdings so
provozieren dass wir das einfach eins
[Musik]
mit euch bei dem akazien baum hier sind
auf jeden fall vier blöcke die hoch
gehen wir sind schon 1234
und jetzt soll er so ein bisschen
seitlich hierüber gehen nämlich hier
einmal und dann noch einen weiter zack
zack zack und hier sollen dann die
blätter dran von denen habe ich jetzt
zwar noch nicht so viele nur 16 stück
allerdings packe ich dir schon mal so
ein bisschen drumherum so dass ihr sieht
wo die reise hingehen soll sagte was ist
deine scheiss vision du kriegst du nie
wieder einen job von mir na ja sogar
sieht gar nicht aus oder
er muss wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
höher egal das wird auf jeden fall das
kriegen wir hin sind dass sie den vier
blöcke ja das sind vier blöcke also anni
der ist doch ein höherer das heißt das
müssen wir dann noch mal einen höher
setzen dass wir da auf jeden fall das
wird cool aussehen lasst euch davon
nicht beirren das ist jetzt gerade noch
nicht so ganz der fall ist ich warte auf
eure tipps und in den kommentaren für
den villiger hier vorne kann ich den weg
noch nicht so richtig weiter machen
allerdings wird das schon
ich würde allerdings an der stelle das
war es von der heutigen episode manchmal
auch mit luca wenn es euch gefallen hat
das kann einen daumen runter video
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr noch kein tabu sein um
die letzten worte hat das schwein
[Musik]